the kremlin's attacks are inflicting an
ever increasing toll on civilians there
hundreds if not thousands of ukrainians
have been killed
many more wounded
as have citizens of other countries
more than a million refugees have fled
ukraine to neighboring countries
millions of people across ukraine
are trapped in increasingly dire
conditions
as russia destroys more critical
infrastructure
for example mario paul's mayor says that
most of the besieged city's residents
are living without water
without electricity without heat
bridges to the city have been destroyed
women children
growing ranks of wounded civilians
cannot get out
food and medical supplies cannot get in
the mayor wrote today and i quote
we are simply being destroyed
the world has seen russia used these
grisly tactics before
in syria
and chechnya
meanwhile
russia's reckless operation
around the zepperiza nuclear power plant
risked a catastrophe a nuclear incident
the kremlin should immediately cease all
attacks around ukrainian nuclear
facilities and allow civilian personnel
to do their work to ensure the facility
safety and security as both the iaea
director general and a resolution
adopted yesterday by the agency's board
of governors have called on russia to do
overnight we saw the russians attacked
this nuclear
power plant last night the u.s embassy
in kiev noted on twitter it is a war
crime to attack a nuclear power plant
putin's shelling of europe's largest
nuclear plant takes his reign of terror
one step further so just to be clear is
it now the position of the us government
that putin has engaged in war crimes
well we have an internal review that's
been ongoing
prior to last night of
to collect evidence and data of
of the targeting of civilians of the
reported use of
horrific weapons of war
on the ground in ukraine that's an
ongoing process we have not made
conclusions it's a legal review and a
process that goes through the
administration what i will say is that
uh the intentional targeting of
civilians or civilian objects would be
considered a war crime even as we are
assessing that uh regardless of the
legality uh this action was the height
of irresponsibility the kremlin must
cease operations
around nuclear infrastructure and we
have of course remaining concerns i
would note that just on the um in the
developments that have happened
overnight as it relates to the nuclear
uh power plant i mean obviously the
russian government's actions were
extremely reckless and dangerous they
could have posed a profound threat uh to
the safety of civilians in the region
and beyond we do applaud the ability of
the ukrainian operators to keep all six
reactors in safe conditions while under
attack and to report as they were able
to
to the nuclear regulator which certainly
was helpful as you know last night the
president not only spoke with president
zielinski he also spoke last night to
the head of the national nuclear
security administration for an update on
the situation at the plant
so that is a piece of positive news
for the moment but we remain concerned
of course about uh the fact that they
have clearly taken control of the plants
or it appears so the russian military
has the best step for nuclear safety
would be for russia to immediately
withdraw its fruit its forces around the
facility we've now seen this really sort
of broad range of bipartisan support
behind this legislation to ban russian
oil import imports the speaker has said
she's all for banning uh russian oil i
guess
just what is your stance on um the
senate bill and is this something that
the president would sign well i think as
we as we talked about a little bit
yesterday um how the president has been
approaching
any of the steps we've taken as it
relates to
russia and the actions of russia and
holding president putin accountable is
to
take every step to the maximum impact
that will impact president putin the
russian economy i mean the stock market
has been closed now for the longest time
in history russia isn't a full-blown
financial crisis according to jp morgan
analyst there will be a co-op collapse
in the russian gdp so clearly those
actions are working uh we will have
one of his principles from the beginning
has been to do that in a unified way in
a coordinated way because we are
stronger if we are together as we work
with the europeans the third principle
or another principle i'm not sure what
number i'm on right now has been to uh
while we're maximizing the impact to
minimize it on the american people on uh
the global markets on and certainly we
are mindful as we look at all of these
options of of making sure we're not
having that impact so we want to
maintain as as dr rouse said a steady
global supply of energy
with whatever actions we take the reason
why we are seeing volatility in the
global oil markets the reason why the
price of gas is going up is not because
of steps the president has taken they
are because president putin is invading
ukraine and that is creating a great
deal of instability in the global
marketplace so what we are trying to do
and what the president is focused on
doing is taking every step we can to
mitigate the impact of that obviously he
announced the release of more
oil from the strategic petroleum reserve
did that in a coordinated way we have a
range of options on the table we are
considering uh but where we are at in
this moment is certainly we are taking
steps to stand up for democracy stand up
for democracy versus autocracy stand up
to the actions of a brutal dictator but
it is because of his actions that we are
in this circumstance senator lindsey
graham said last night that someone
ought to assassinate the president who
does the white house have any take on
that statement is it helpful at this
point that is not the position of the
united states government and certainly
not a statement you'd hear from come
from the mouth of anybody working in
this administration